quem olha que chorava você está aqui
lembra de quando a casa da minha avó que
eu sei que todo mundo tenha robô e avó
com que a gente vai passar as férias na
casa de quem dava ruim a não quero
ninguém em casa
quanto à casa dela e tenta ser humano
fantástico melhor curta carnaval que
comida unida tem muita falta telha
parede não tem paredes para ir não tem
comida tem vai ficar na volta ligando
pra outra mulher mas está tudo bem
mulher e aí como é que tá pensando que o
neto mulher meu está com 65 foi o meu
deus meu taco 80 é essa história e já o
prazo mais curto a fazer outro mundo mas
que é meta da cabeça de washington
enquanto 40 quilos vai votar com 91
scheid nutrida cada voto aparece no que
digo à minha volta não saber falar meu
nome é o hino hino indo aí uma criança
não sabe escrever meu nome tentava
prender não conseguia eu ainda me
chamaria o hino resultar cresceu bug
roda serviu a essa roda a cidade não sei
mas vote interior agora ser de mais cara
porque ela não tem diversão a pessoa
janta falou que depois não me engano
sete horas da noite agora cinco da manhã
acorda segue até 29 lago do tão cedo que
ainda está montando a roleta do boneco
paninho a gente acorda todo dia você vai
pra escola foi meu deus ela nessas
férias eu vou dormir muito para a minha
casa da avó quem é que está lá há cinco
horas da manhã pra acordar você nem a
vovó milan resta muito mal acostumado em
dominar até maquiagem é um herói de
aventura épica e mesmo a 1 pela bolívia
já dormiu mal o meu deus era tudo que
ele não transfere a bola corre pra quê
pra comer carne tem que fazer comida
para os comendo um amigo aqui conosco
sem colete com a hora que for interior
têm raiva assim que elas a corda feita a
varrer o quintal ea deixa tudo na rede
na mesma direção fica bem bonitinho que
estava aí começa a jogar bola brincar
cavassin pai começa a deixar o quintal
quando chega o buraco assim né não vocês
só vêm pra cá vai ficar na capital é
fácil né meu pedacinho imola e parece
bom que eu fiz agora que vão gostar é
quando a gente leva os amigos pra casa
chega brilho e meu deus vou fazer tanta
comida meu deus eu vou nutrir essas
crianças é o caminho começa a brincar
papa jogando bola no terreno
ela fica agoniada meu deus mas ela tem
uma técnica e uma técnica para atrair as
crianças um menino cabeça e fazer um
lanche
parece-nos grêmio e sim do sul de bagdá
e tem é comer bem a doença na casa de
voto em deputados e pode chegar na casa
da sua avó todo verde boi caiu ontem vou
ganhar diarreia iphone o resto é o resto
é treta estreia fora farão cacho uma
perna quebrada ela vai lá no quintal
pego umas folhas cascas de talbot de um
copo de morte febre do minuto 19 bete
fica bonzinho na hora melhorou meu filho
melhorei voto 11 banda que acompanhará
sempre bom quando tem uma vez que ela
sai do chão não deixou o bebê tudo que
só vai deixar bebê todo gol é para
melhorar mas não é para melhorar todo
para deixar as pernas do então você não
joga bola e ela acabou quintal está bom
e quando obriga o meu deus do céu que
tem que escutar a briga dela pra gente e
pra mãe da gente é caiu caiu porque
danado fez saber que tomando é do coxa
direita a tua mãe não tinha do coxa
direita apanhado era muito eu posso até
não posso bater o que só volto sou mãe a
seu posto a mãe teve um tempo que eu
morei na casa da minha avó eu fui
estudar lá passei um ano como eu e minha
vai bem no império não sabe nem ler nem
escrever
acho que passei o ano todinho
vagabundando a escola chegou no final do
ano eu fiquei em recuperação é mostrar o
boletim com a minha bom mesmo é mostrar
isso toma volta aqui meu boi tish de
nota vermelha estava na recuperação e
matemática e física quinca a foi de
recuperação em ação
eu fiquei no papel assim já está dizendo
aqui ele pra eu tá tá dizendo feliz
natal e um próspero ano novo a assim
tanto passou é parceiro eu passei cinco
bom vou fazer um bolo para comemorar a
atar e não sei que vou ter um bolo de
chocolate ela só acho que é porque é
feita em diabetes é que o novo fica o
diabetes também você vai gostar desse
evento já sabe qual tem aqui no youtube
volta lá no facebook na postagem de
porto velho novo clique em curtir
descreve entrar para o pv
obrigado a assistir até que é nós falou